start off this hour with Joshua and
Illinois hey Joshua how are you oh my
god hi Dave huge fan achillion pockety
well I'm honored sir how can I help
well first off let me just say that I've
been reading your book and you really
inspired me to take more control be more
responsible for my financial future and
I was calling today to ask you a
question about this student loan
settlement that I've been offered but
basically I've got a $42,000 student
loan debt that they offered to settle
for $6,000 now with that I understand
that there are tax ramifications that
will incur on the remaining balance of
$36,000 however on my research I can't
find what percentage I will be taxed at
so I've gotten the contractual agreement
to extend up to April 20-21 and I need
to figure out how much I need to save
for the IRS oh okay
and the this must be a private student
loan that yes and that's one of the
things that it's a bit shady sort of
what's been going on with the Naviance
student loans and dis and my school that
I went to so one of the things that I'm
worried about is the fact that I would
have to give up my right to pursue any
legal action should there be some sort
of lawsuit
afterwards I wouldn't worry about that
you got out of 42,000 dollars worth of
mess you got into for six grand you
think it so you think it's a good deal
then you got it in writing yeah I have
the contractual yeah mm-hmm okay and are
you working yes I'm currently working in
what do you learn on 78 okay
about 20 percent 15 percent of the
difference will be at your taxes
whatever tax bracket you're in is what
will apply you'll get a 1099 for the
amounts debt forgiveness is a is taxable
income and yeah the amount you said the
difference in forty two and six is what
they're the thirty six thousand
is what yeah and so if you're at 20% at
7 grand
ok another 7 grand
yeah my favorite 20% 20% if you're at
you know 15% it's going to be obviously
about 5 grand so somewhere in that range
is where you're you can give your tax
preparer and they can go ahead and tell
you but between now and April that's
what you're gonna have to come up with
or you're gonna have an IRS problem
after you got rid of your student loan
problem okay that's that's assuming
these bozos at navient actually are
competent enough to get the 1099 out to
you this year it might think I'm a year
to get around to sending you the 1099
okay and until you get the 1099 I
wouldn't pay any taxes okay but I should
still prepare for that yeah you need to
act like it's coming because it probably
is if they never sends you a 1099 then I
would not pay taxes on it okay I would
only renowned to the 1099 okay so okay
and at this in addition to that I have
76 in federal loans and my wife has 30
so after I pay off this 9 grand on my
car we should focus on her student loans
right and just make the minimum payments
on my federal loans yes minimum payments
on everything but your smallest debt
attack your smallest debt when it's
gonna attack the next one down when it's
gonna attack the next one down however
your budget has now been affected by
whatever you calculate your taxes to be
divided into your monthly budget so that
you're ready for April right well I got
the agreement to extend out my last
payment so January of 2020 so then the
tax notifications won't incur until
April 20-21 okay watch good move yeah it
strategy
yeah I did yeah I did that just he's
already no problems in an old on my 12
or what because of my wife's income if
we file together but put yourself put
yourself some kind of an email tickler
in your file or something to wake you
back up next summer to start planning
for that okay yes of course thank you so
much Dave I appreciate the advice yes
sounds like you're being very proactive
and very careful and very diligent well
done
way to go you digging out brother you
it out you can do it